So you talked about the need for a four day workweek or someone like to say a
three-day weekend.
Yes, I did the math.
Either one of those works. So I was all right,
as I looked into this and I think, you know, this,
like I was looking in the history of weekends and really it started, I mean,
there's been, they've been around for awhile, but it really was a union thing.
Right. Like the unions demanded like, Hey, um,
we get two days off, like that's the move? And it was in, uh,
right after the great depression, if I recall.
Yeah. Yeah. It was in the, um,
the fair labor standards act of 1938, 40 hour work week.
Well, first let me, let me explain the thinking behind it, where right now,
uh, our work week is getting longer, not shorter. Uh,
and it's having a disastrous set of effects on
millions of people where, uh,
we have this mental health crisis that we talked about last week. Um, we,
we have, uh, this worship of work, work ism, um,
and, uh, we're sleep deprived. I mean, you can name it there,
like all these stacked effect, uh, and it's getting worse now,
economists like canes projected we'd have a 15 hour work week by now because
we'd be so wealthy and it turns out he was right about the level of wealth like
that, that blind was correct. Um,
but he obviously got the number of hours in the work week,
very wrong because it's been getting longer, not shorter, um, here in the us.
Uh,
and Barack Obama actually said to me that we should be looking at a shorter work
week because, uh, firms aren't going to, um,
employ people in the same way that they have previously.
So let's see what happens if you do, uh,
implement three-day weekends four day work week.
The big thing people say is like, well, won't you then just do 20% less work.
And that's not really the way it happens in real life where organizations
actually become more productive in many cases. Um,
if you shorten the work week and if you think about the way most of us work,
uh, we have bursts of productivity and then bursts of relative.
Like I'm not really doing a whole lot right now. Um,
and those bursts tend to correspond to when the
deadline is, but also what our schedule is like,
I'll give you an example. Um,
the most productive day that anyone has is the day before they're gone,
they go on vacation for awhile. Like, uh, like that, like that day,
all of a sudden it's like, you know, just get so much stuff done.
Oh, he knows that feeling too. Yeah. So this just getting done this done today.
So your productivity, um,
expands or contracts depending upon the schedule.
And that's why if you have a four day work week,
you may get the exact same amount done as you wouldn't a five day work week,
just get it done in less time. Um,
so let's stipulate that productivity let's say stays the same,
even though studies have shown it'll actually go up now, then,
then you have a three-day weekend, um,
which ends up improving your level of rest,
your mental health, your relationships, your time with family. Uh,
it actually has even been shown to, uh, help, um,
more evenly distributed, like domestic responsibilities, uh,
so that there are all of these positive effects. Um,
and the negative effects are, as far as I can tell,
quite absent in the data and here's the kicker.
It would help create jobs at the margins because if you're a firm
and you have a four day work week, and let's say you need coverage, um,
then you might have to hire another, like, you know,
20% of people and then like have them work different periods of time.
Uh, so,
and right now we're in a situation where we need to create jobs in the worst way
where we're going to be short tens of millions of jobs for months. Uh,
so anything we can do, that's going to stimulate hiring is a win. Um,
so the,
the four day workweek to me is something that we should be seriously looking at.
And the way you make it happen is the same way you made the two day work week
happen, which is you, uh, pass a law saying, Hey, guess what?
Like these are going to be the expected work hours. Like,
of course you can have a firm that has people work different, uh,
hours, but then you have to, um,
accommodate your employees and like, you know, additional ways. And like, it's,
you know, um, Franklin.
That's the dumb question? Is it like, is it it's a law? And so right now we,
the weekend essentially structured on the 40 hour work week.
You're not allowed to have a number of workers and a lot of work more than 40
hours a week if it's an hourly worker. Right. And so after a certain level,
right. And so you would make overtime after 30 hours or whatever.
Well, you know, you, yeah. I mean, you could,
you could work with the number of hours you could, uh,
like there are different ways you could make the, um,
the weekend longer. Uh,
I have a feeling though that it wouldn't take that much. Um,
because if you were to pass a law in this direction,
a lot of major companies would adopt it.
And then it's going to be very difficult for some companies to look up and say
like, actually, we're going to ignore that.
Like when literally their competitor companies are hiring,
the same people are doing, it's like,
and so it's really interesting if you're an employee,
like which company you're going to choose, you're going to choose the one that,
that with the four day work week. Um, and so they're going to end up with like,
you know,
better people who are going to have the same level of productivity and higher
contentment levels and better rest. You know,
it's like one of the signs to me about how sleep deprived we are is that when
you have daylight savings time, when you lose an hour of sleep,
car accidents go up, like, literally if like you,
you have like one less hour sleep,
it screws us up enough where we're actually like,
like a non-trivial number of us are going to like, get an accident. Right. Uh,
so it's like, there's, and I'm, you know,
it's fun to have this conversation right now, like after Memorial day, because,
uh, you know, it's like that three day weekend, I was saying, it's like,
it's 50% better than a two day weekend. You know, you'll, you'll come back in,
you'll come back into the office, like much more ready to go.
You'll be more productive from front to back. Right. And there,
there are many workers, obviously that like aren't in this world.
So some people I know are looking to be like, well,
it doesn't apply to me because like, I'm like, you know, I've got a job that I,
medicine medicine, or it's like, I get paid hourly. So like,
what are you talking about? Um, so, so there,
there have to be ways that we make it, uh, like a universal, basic income, uh,
make it so that people are able to, uh,
work and not feel like they have to work themselves to the bone,
the way that many, many people do right now.
Is there an argument that economic activity will be boosted
because you have more weekends? Like do people spend,
I don't know if you know these numbers, do people spend more on the weekends?
I imagine, yes. When you have free time, that's when you're going to dinner,
that's when you're going on vacation. And that's when you're traveling this,
when you're spending more on gas, who knows?
Yeah, of course. You know,
of course we spend more and more money on recreational stuff on weekends, uh,
than when you're working. Like, you know,
all you can do is eat lunch at your desk and whatnot. Right. Um,
the economy that is stimulative.
Yup. The, but I also think this, I think this,
it clearly pinched a nerve on Twitter when you, when you,
when you tweeted it out.
So that's why I wanted to explore it more with you in this.
And you talked about this a lot personally, and on the trail like this,
the why of like, it begs the question, why are we working?
You know what I'm saying? Um, and I think you.
It's obvious Zack, where we're working to maximize GDP. Like,
have you made your GDP contribution today? If not, then you.
Um, but you've kind of argued that work is activity that makes society better.
Um, theoretically and now.
Oh, I love to work. Don't get me wrong. I've, I've learned that the hard way,
man.
That Ronnie Chang thing where like Asians don't take off,
they don't stop for Christmas. They don't stop for Thanksgiving.
Like that's yang man. Like, there's like, Oh man, all day, I love that. Um,
you like finish your presidential run and you just kept working. Um,
you're insane. But, um, the, I,
we were joking on our team, Andrews.
The irony of we're going to work with the irony is we're going to work a seven
day work week to fight for a four day work week around the rest of the country.
Yeah. That's pretty good summary, man. Um, so here's,
here's the thing too, is like, if, if you have a four-day work week, um,
and you're someone who likes to work, then you know what you're gonna do,
you're gonna get tons of work done during those four days.
And then those other three days,
you're going to do different types of work on like yourself, your family,
your health, your relationships, your community, like you'll find stuff to do.
Uh, if you want to work, like nothing's going to keep you from, from working,
but you'll get the same amount of work done in less time.
Yeah. I'm a fan. I was on the fence at first. I was like, wait,
we changed this up. And I,
I think there's a lot of arguments in the pro column and not a lot arguments in
the con column, but the here's the money shot. Andrew,
do you pick Monday or Friday?
Uh, my instinct is you pick Friday because I don't get done on Fridays.
I'm just kidding. Um,
but, uh, you know, I mean,
another thing you do is you could just like let a company choose and then you'd
have some companies, uh, in effect Monday. And, uh, some companies in fact,
Friday, if, if you were like a certain type of business, but generally speaking,
you'd want to pick the same day for most companies so that, um,
so that everyone would have the benefits,
because one of the things you realize quickly is that weekends are best when
they're synchronous. If you want someone to be sad, um,
you give them time off when no one else has time off. Yeah. So,
so, so generally speaking, we would just pick Fridays, um, um,
I think that would be the win.